>> Anita's question is definitely the right
question to ask. I have to say frankly it's
incredibly impressive that The Girl Effect
topic is one of the main topic on the Davos
agenda this year, especially considering the
incredibly challenging financial crisis that
we're working through so to have this on the
main agenda, on the Davos agenda, in frankly
one of the most popular sessions here amidst
this period of time, is important. Because
here we are amidst the world's top business
and political leaders all listening and understanding
better how important it is for us to focus
on supporting adolescent girls in developing
countries around the world, all 600 million
of them, who really frankly need that support
from all of us. They happen to be one of the
most neglected, unsupported, at risk parts
of the global population and our ability to
support them can actually create the most
impact I think in terms of specific parts
of the population around the world. Helping
them realize their potential will really help
us as a world population reach our potential.
Thank you.